well I didn't talk about this book when
I was writing it for five or six years
so when i whenever you know read any of
the reviews that have come out so far my
first response is is kind of still
surprise and excitement that someone
read my book that I didn't it the idea
that other people are reading what i
wrote and was sort of thinking about 45
years is still astonishing to me on some
level maybe i'll get past that soon but
whether they have good things to say or
bad things to say I'm kind of just want
to thank them for reading my book I feel
like it's really exciting so I'm still
at that phase I maybe there'll be a time
when I'm really bitter and angry or my
mood you'll have to go to bed if I read
a negative review or something but at
this point I'm it's just exciting to me
that people are reading things that I
wrote and it's a very strange idea
you